merci d'être là bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
mais écoutez on a fait aussi une
révision de nos tableaux de bord dans
les derniers jours parce que
l'indicateur dont vous parlez c'est pas
qu'il est pas bon mais il doit être
complété par d'autres prenons le code de
l'hôpital juif oui on a un taux
d'occupation qui est compté sur le
nombre de civières qui sont occupés mais
il faut regarder aussi le temps de
traitement que ça prend des gens par
exemple
attendent 4 heures ou 11h ou 18h alors
l'hôpital juif est souvent notre
meilleur exemple parce que oui en ce
moment ils ont des gros taux
d'occupation particulièrement raison des
enfants mais en même temps il
réussissent avoir des temps d'attente
pour l'urgence qui sont très
raisonnables donc c'est un peu ça des
meilleurs pratiques que notre cellule de
crise est en train de regarder pour
améliorer sur le modèle entre autres du
de l'Hôpital général juif les nos
différentes urgences à travers le Québec
pour mieux passer à travers cette crise
rappelez-moi léchés ainsi que vous avez
en tête pour voir quand même ces
chiffres-là diminués il y a les
cliniques qui vont ouvrir il y a
différentes mesures vous aviez annoncé
il y a deux semaines est-ce que jusqu'à
Noël on doit on doit vivre avec des taux
qui seront quand même très très élevés
bon on va on va continuer à vivre avec
des taux élevés comme par exemple le
taux d'occupation des civières parce que
ça ça prend un certain temps mais déjà
on a vu des améliorations depuis la puis
même avant j'allais dire depuis la mise
en place de la cellule on a commencé
prenons par exemple une façon de dégager
les urgences c'est de s'assurer que nos
liés à l'étage sont libérés plus
rapidement pour que les gens qui sont
sursivière puissent monter à l'étage et
libérer les urgences on a vu des
améliorations puis je rentrerai pas dans
le détail de nos tableaux de bord mais
maintenant les Québécois sont capables
d'aller voir ces variations là moi
j'essaye ça nos nos signes encourageants
que plusieurs des choses ont fonction
par exemple là on avait promis deux
cliniques qu'on appelle des IPS sur
l'île de Montréal la bonne nouvelle que
j'ai eu c'est comment être capable d'en
faire trois alors ça aussi c'est une
bonne nouvelle ça va continuer avec
comment
je vous parle de visite
l'interface pour le public pour les
diriger vous vous avez voulu simplifier
ça aussi
mais merci de le rappeler parce que
avant c'était peut-être un peu compliqué
de savoir à quel numéro appeler on a
changé ça on a vu que ça fonctionnait
pas notre goût là maintenant les gens
peuvent appeler au 81 je le répète si
par exemple c'est dans le cas de pour
les enfants donc zéro à 17 ans vous
allez faire le 2 et là si vous êtes sur
l'île de Montréal puis dans les
prochaines heures ça va être à monter
régie l'anaudière etc les gens vont être
capables de prendre un rendez-vous pour
vous dans une clinique donc il y a
vraiment des admirations qui sont en
train d'être mis en place mais on le
souhaite puis on va suivre ça évidemment
avec vous mais en attendant le réseau
est sous pression le sud évidence et
vous dites le masque peut peut-être nous
éviter des visites à l'urgence qu'on
prend pas de chance et là vous
recommander que les gens dans les lieux
publics fermés en transport en commun il
va sans dire théâtre
quoi d'autre Léa enfin bref les
libibliothèques vous recommandez
fortement le port du masque en fait ce
qu'on a dit Monsieur roi on a dit des
lieux publics qui sont achalandés et je
vous donne l'exemple vous avez un
exemple de aller dans un restaurant vous
êtes deux personnes puis l'autre table
est à trois tables de vous il y a pas de
poste cette obligation on se fie
beaucoup au jugement des gens que
lorsqu'ils vont aller dans un endroit
public ça peut être un cinéma c'est la
proximité qui est un élément important à
tenir en compte donc on a décidé de se
fier aux juments après trois ans de
pandémie je pense que la plupart des
Québécois savent un peu comment se
comporter et donc cette espèce de
comportement citoyen là on le on va
l'expliquer mais je pense que les gens
comprennent qu'il faut être prudents
avez-vous jonglé monsieur le ministre
avec parce que vous venez de le dire
vous avez employé le mot il y a pas
d'obligation dans un restaurant où on
est très loin en voulant dire il y
aurait une obligation si on est dans un
centre d'achat tout collé mais il y aura
pas d'obligation avez-vous jonglé avec
l'idée de l'obliger quand même non
c'est évident que on est passé à autre
chose je le répète monsieur Royan on a
été longtemps dans un concept de
d'obligation pour une foule de raison
rappelez-vous il y avait pas de
vaccination tout ça non mais n'est
jamais temps peuvent se faire vacciner
les gens peuvent et je pense que quand
on regarde l'ensemble des mesures
sanitaires de ton parle comme par
exemple le masque je pense que ces
mesures là pour faire que les gens avec
leur habitude je le répète des dernières
années sont capables de poser les bons
humains et on se fit à se comportement
citoyen là qui devrait être exemplaire
ça fait partie du passé ces obligations
là voilà
un mot avant de vous laisser aller la
deuxième dose de rappel on les appelle
comme ça maintenant on les compte plus
de 1 à 4 à 5 là deuxième dose de rappel
on est en retard là ces petits mais on
peut le voir au Québec c'est 15,8 on est
parmi l'alberté un tout petit peu en
dessous de nous
ça va moins vite au Québec là vous avez
vous avez fait une pub d'ailleurs que le
Père Noël et le temps est faite arrive
c'est qu'est-ce que vous dites aux gens
qu'est-ce que la santé publique dit aux
gens allez-y même si vous êtes en santé
on dit deux choses qui est important
c'est de respecter le plus possible le
délai de 5 mois si ça fait plus que 5
mois que vous avez reçu votre deuxième
dose de rappel puis je dirais
particulièrement avant les fêtes où il
va y avoir plus de contact il faut aller
chercher cette dose de rappel là moi le
chiffre que je regarde c'est pas
uniquement l'échelle du Québec les
chiffres que vous venez de tester mais
pour les catégories d'âge de personnes
qui sont plus âgées vous savez au-dessus
de 80 ans le pourcentage est rendu au
dessus de 60 % et ça c'est sans compter
que des personnes dans ce qui ont
peut-être faites la covid comme
protection additionnelle donc je le
regarde par catégorie d'âge parce que
c'est ça qu'il faut protéger c'est
protéger nos gens de plus
je vous laisse aller monsieur Dubé
ministre de la Santé du Québec à très
bientôt merci à bientôt monsieur